hi I'm Charlie puth and this is the
wired autocomplete interview
can I say that who is Charlie Otto poof
Otto is my middle name
it's German who is Charlie Otto poof jr.
that makes me the second my dad is also
Charles Otto booth who does Charlie puth
look like a lot of people say I look
like Mark Ronson and Josh Hutcherson and
Josh Hutchinson who did Charlie puth I'm
nervous for this one hoon and Charlie
puth write songs for I've written songs
for most recently 5 seconds of summer
random collection of people Jason Derulo
that was like one of the first artists I
ever wrote for I I can never remember I
wrote for a lot of people and frankly
very surprised that people want to get
in the room with me who is Charlie puth
best friend my best friend is a guy
named Adam crane house key I went to
college with him he was my college
roommate my first college roommate I
think he's watching this right now
here we go there is questions is Charlie
puth British no really really not is
Charlie puth a tenor interesting
question I think sometimes I am
sometimes I can be an alto I think
sometimes it can be a soprano as well
maybe most of the time tenor is trying
to puth in engineer a grammy-nominated
engineer pretty cool is charlie proof
related to Stephen booth I think that's
fairly obvious is Charlie proof each win
no common misconception my sister is
twins with my brother we all kind of
just look alike where Charlie puth this
is the where Charlie puth card I'm so
tired of saying Charlie puth where
Charlie puth from Charlie puth from New
Jersey Rumson New Jersey where to
download Charlie puth songs you can
download Charlie puth song on LimeWire
and Kazaa and bearshare and BitTorrent
and you know the little kiosk in
Brooklyn where was Charlie puth raised
Charlie puth was raised in Rumson New
Jersey where is Charlie puth parents
from
how did I not know that my parents are
both from New Jersey where did Charlie
puth go to high school I went to Rumson
Fair Haven Regional High School in
Rumson New Jersey and boy did it suck
next card what songs did Charlie puth
write I write all of my songs I produce
all my songs actually mix all my songs -
but I've written a lot for other artists
as well what is going on charlie puth
and there's supposed to be a question
mark at the end of it
what is Charlie puth favorite color
green what height is Charlie puth I
think six-foot exactly what is Charlie
puth biography
oh no I probably get someone to write it
for me is Charlie puth in any movies no
I would like to be in a movie that
doesn't require me acting like someone
else because I think I'm a terrible
actor is Charlie puth Italian I think
maybe a little bit I got to do that
ancestry.com thing is Charlie puth good
know is Charlie puth left-handed no but
my mom is I'm right-handed is Charlie
puth vegan really really know how
Charlie puth how is Charlie puth
pronounced Charlie puth how long charlie
puth lyrics I think that was just an
expressway to get the lyrics to my song
how long because if it wasn't that than
I really don't know how to answer that
how tall Charlie puth meaning what how
long Charlie puth chords Oh someone was
searching for the chords of my song it's
funny when my song title is actually a
question how is Charlie puth you know
probably nervous most of the time but
pretty nice guy this is the last card
what is charlie puth charlie puth is a
person Charlie Prince a singer what is
the age of Charlie puth what a weird way
to ask that question I am 27 years old
what is with Charlie puth eyebrow I was
bit by a dog when I was 2 years old
looks kind of cool now what is Charlie
puth nationality I think it's pretty
obvious what is Charlie puth real name
my real name is Charles Otto pujan
your'e thanks so much for watching I
think everybody has to work on the
grammar just a little bit but I
appreciate all the questions and I know
thought that people would be googling me
one day so that's pretty cool